not since Matthew McConaughey we're talk  about this today has there been more  shirtless photos oh god of any man alive  you really went there huh well Andy had  them you and Putin yeah unbelievable  you've got photos you don't need to be  shirtless yeah there's one yeah there's  some photos there you're wearing jeans  in the water  that's just my father would be so proud  that's good this is not good  no there's shots of you shirtless  leaving the you know the the whatever  the ATM you know there's there's no  reason for you not to have a shirt on  what's going on I am covered at all  times I do that not just because I'm Sun  sensitive but for the city wait that's  actually yeah that's good well you know  vitamin D I guess I don't know so you  look fantastic  I say that in a sexual way I said I am  not gay but were I to be gay you'd be  the guy I believe based on those photos  and I just I just it's a ton of work  that's almost what I look like  you